hey this is Prussia Walker how many
triangles are there in this picture I
saw this puzzle on the st. Louis Science
Center Twitter account and I'll admit it
was very challenging for me and I could
not get the correct answer luckily for
me they did tweet out the correct answer
but since I was not able to solve it I
thought it might be challenging for many
of you so I wanted to share it with you
can you figure out how many triangles
there are in this picture there are no
counting tricks this is just a good
old-fashioned test of your observational
ability can you figure it out give this
a try and when you're ready keep
watching the video for the answer so the
actual number of triangles in this
picture is 26 so it's a little bit
difficult to explain where each triangle
is in this cluttered diagram so what I'm
going to do is build up the diagram
triangle by triangle and show you where
each triangle is so let's start out with
three of the big triangles we have 1 2 &
3 so far so good now let's introduce
another triangle that's upside down
let's do the large triangle that's
upside down this actually creates many
more triangles we of course have the
upside down triangle this will be
triangle 4 we then have triangles 5 6 &
7 next we have these very small
triangles 8 & 9
this is triangle 10 here we have
triangle 11 12 13 and 14 so we're up to
14 triangles now let's introduce the
next upside-down triangle
this adds one more triangle so this is
15 here we have 16 and 17 this is 18 and
19 and we've one more at the top which
is 20 so up to 20 and now we have one
more upside-down triangle this adds one
more to get to 21 now we have a couple
of smaller triangles here we have 22 23
we have some really small triangles 24
and 25 and for a long time I couldn't
figure out where the last triangle was
and then I suddenly saw it it was this
upper triangle right here this is
triangle 26 so that's where all the 26
triangles come from now just for fun let
me put them all in one diagram Wow 26
triangles in this diagram did you find
all of them thanks for watching this
video please subscribe to my channel I
make videos on math you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions if you like
this video you can check out my books
which are listed in the video
description and you can support me on
patreon if you have a topic suggestion
you can email me presh and mind your
decisions comm you can catch me on
social media either and mind your
decisions or a pressure Locker